.
THANK YOU.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN ERIC
REINHART.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON THE
SHOW.
BY SIGNING CONSENT FORMS, DID
THE FATHER ESSENTIALLY SAY HE
WOULD BE LIABLE FOR THE SON'S
USE OF THE FIREARM?
DID THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE
WHEN THE SUSPECT TURNED 21.
HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND THIS.
>> YEAH.
SURE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON THE
SHOW.
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO EXPRESS MY
CONDOLENCES TO THOSE WHO LOST
LOVED ONES, DAMAGED IN THIS
TERRIBLE ATTACK.
HIGHLAND PARK WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME.
I HAVE TO COMMEND FIRST
RESPONDERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
WHO RAN TOWARD THE DANGER AND
APPREHENDED THIS OFFENDER.
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION, THERE IS
NOT A CRIMINAL LIABILITY THAT'S
DIRECTLY ATTACHED TO
QUOTE/UNQUOTE VOUCHING FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE BUT WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE EVIDENCE.
THERE'S A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE
TO GO THROUGH.
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS TO LOOK
AT POTENTIAL CRIMINAL LIABILITY
IN THIS CASE.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY MUCH MORE
OTHER THAN THAT BUT THERE'S NOT
A PER SE VIOLATION OF LAW IF YOU
VOUCH FOR SOMEBODY ON AN FOID
CARD AND DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO INVESTIGATE AND
EXPLORE ALL OPTIONS.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK HIS REQUEST
WAS GRANTED?
>> YEAH.
THE ILLINOIS AND HIGHLAND PARK
POLICE DEPARTMENT NOTIFIED THE
STATE POLICE OF THE INCIDENT AND
THE ONLY STATE POLICE HAD THAT
RECORD.
NOW AT THE TIME THAT THEY WERE
RECEIVING THE RECORD THERE'S NO
PENDING APPLICATION SO THAT HAS
TO BE POINTED OUT.
THERE WASN'T A FIREARM AS
SUSPECT.
THERE'S A STATEMENT ON THE
WEBSITE.
I WOULD DEFER TO THEM.
>> OKAY.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT JUST
THE RED FLAGS.
IN SO MANY CASES WE SEE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN RED FLAGS.
THE SHOOTER SAYING THINGS.
DISTURBED SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS.
NOW IN HINDSIGHT IT IS ALL
ALARMING.
HOW DOES LAW ENFORCEMENT LINK
THE WARNING SIGNS AND THEN A
HUGE ONE PAINTED ON A HOUSE?
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE TO ALWAYS HAVE BETTER
CONNECTIVITY WITH THE SYSTEMS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SYSTEMS, COURT
SYSTEMS, SCHOOL SYSTEMS, MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE TO RESPECT PRIVACY BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE COURTS
ARE GOOD AT KEEPING INFORMATION
PRIVATE IN A LOT OF SITUATIONS
AND CAN'T LET THE RULES ALLOW
THE LEFT HAND TO NOT KNOW WHAT
THE RIGHT HAND IS DOING.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT HAPPENED
IN THIS CASE.
THERE'S NO CONTACT WITH THE
COURT SYSTEM OR THE PROSECUTOR'S
OFFICE IN THAT 2019, 2020 PERIOD
OR SINCE.
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER TO MAKE
SURE THE INFORMATION IS MOVING
TOWARD THE ILLINOIS STATE POLICE
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET FIREARMS.
WE ALSO SHOULD BAN THESE TYPES
OF ASSAULT WEAPONS.
IT WORKED IN 1994 FOR TEB TEN
YEARS.
WE HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT.
IN THAT